en tunisie maintenant la situation
épidémique est extrêmement compliqué le
nombre de cas explose et les hôpitaux
sont débordés
le ministre de la santé critiqué pour sa
campagne vaccinale a été limogé à faouzi
mehdi a été remercié par le chef du
gouvernement sans explication l ex
ministre de la santé avait annoncé une
ouverture temporaire de la vaccination à
tous les tunisiens de plus de 18 ans est
créé dans une ruée sur les centres et
l'obligeant à restreindre de nouveau les
conditions de vaccination pour éviter la
cohue
à l'heure actuelle seulement 8% des
tunisiens ont reçu les deux doses du
vaccin anti coville est les détails avec
notre correspondant à bassam chebi à
tunis en pleines crises sanitaires et
politiques le ministre de la santé à
tunisian faouzi mehdi a été limogé par
monsieur mechiche il est chef du
gouvernement il a été remercié et
remplacé par mohamed trabelsi qui
actuellement les ministres des affaires
sociales nommé trabelsi qui devient
ministre par intérim de la santé dans un
pays qui connaît une recrudescence
importante des cas de coven un virus et
une recrudescence des décès un chiffre
de décès le plus important du magret
pour un pays qui compte à peine 12
millions d'habitants
la campagne de vaccination tente est
atterré par le gouvernement ou les
personnes de plus de 50 ans et certains
corps de métiers notamment les blouses
blanches et puis les militaires étaient
à vacciner 8% de la population seulement
en tunisie est vacciné le premier jour
de la fête de l'aïd el-kébir la fed
religieuse a plus importants du
calendrier est musulman hier 29 centres
de vaccination étaient ouverts à travers
tout le pays une vaccination massive
ouverte à tous qui a écrit la cohue dans
certains centres et certaines villes où
on pouvait voir des files d'attentes
assez importante la tunisie qui a
proposé est cette campagne de
vaccination pour tous alors qu'elle ne
dispose que de 3,2 millions de doses de
vaccins
elle espère en disposer de plus de cinq
millions d'ici le mois d'août notamment
grâce à la solidarité et l'aide
internationale selon les blouses
blanches
il faudrait vacciner plus de cent mille
personnes par jour pour ralentir cette
recrudescence des cas à deux co vide
alors qu'actuellement on vaccine à peu
près 40 mille personnes par jour le
vraiment pointé du doigt notamment sur
sa gestion de la crise avait dû
coronavirus et notamment concernant une
réunion qui a été organisée dans la
ville balnéaire d'hammamet dans un hôtel
de luxe à voir que les tunisiens ont été
a demandé de rester chez eux et de
limiter leur circulation
la tunisie qui connaît toujours une
crise politique et une crise sanitaire
assez important temps de sortir de cette
impasse notamment grâce à l'aide
internationale
on compte actuellement plus de 550 me
des cas positifs au coronavirus avec un
chiffre de décès qui atteindrait 17 1664
depuis le début de l'épidémie